then he said this line that he left he
goes that sounds silly I understand that
that my whole day is just about posting
on Twitter
but everybody's just got a thing that's
my thing okay and he's like we've all
got one thing that's my thing
I love it
[Music]
all right we have a special episode
we're gonna talk about cool content that
we've consumed this might be short 20 25
minutes but you want to kick things off
yeah well I want to say why I think this
is a good type of episode to do we um
yeah one of the best ways to change your
life is to change like your if you don't
change your body you'll go change your
diet uh or your habits your workout
habits or your eating habits uh if you
want to change your mind you need to
change your info diet and so one of the
questions I like asking and I know you
do too which is like you're like it's
like the dorkiest question ever we
probably should find a better way to
phrase it no it's a great question but
it's the answer is so good that we don't
even care how lame the question sounds
but I've heard you say this before like
so what media are you consuming so what
are you like what are you reading
nowadays or like what content do you
like to consume which is I do that in
job interviews and people will be like
oh I read like The New York Times I'm
like no come on like what subreddits are
you like consuming do you use Reddit
what about Twitter on Instagram who do
you follow what where are you getting
who who's influencing you that's yeah
Palmer lucky this we were like what
reddits what subreddits do you go on
because his brain was it was like he's
firing off all these awesome things in
all these different areas it's like that
doesn't just happen by accident that
happens because he's got a set of
interesting inputs that leads to a set
of interesting outputs we as MFM want to
be one of those interesting inputs for
you so that you become a more
interesting smart uh you know person
based off of listening to this but we're
just one thing so what we want to share
is what are the best of the inputs that
we read listened to or watched this week
then maybe you should go check out so
that's the premise of this
um I wish more people did this of people
that I find interesting I wish they
would be more
um I wish they would curate for me like
yo here's the one or two best things I
read or watched this week or listened to
just to get my mind going and show me
cool things I should go go do anyways
that's the Spiel I want you to kick it
off
um I want you to do the top two uh all
three years are good so once you kick it
off with the top one so one of the best
things I watched this week is Bill
gurley's talk at all in have you heard
his his talk that he did at the all-in
conference yeah so he did a talk I
believe it was about Uber and Regulation
and like some of the surprising things
they found so Bill Gurley was the like
lead investor in Uber
um and he goes to all in and I expected
him to talk about I don't know Venture
Capital uh business investing but he's
now retired he's a retired VC so he's
like
kind of in the No Flex given mode which
is great like you know when you get a
really smart person who now feels like
they have nothing to lose they can go
off and I feel like that's the best way
to describe this it wasn't a talk Bill
Gurley went off and so what he does is
the talk is titled I think it's like
2851 or something like that some number
and he he's basically the talk is like
that's the number of miles between
Silicon Valley and Washington DC and
what he does is he talks about
regulation and how screwed up it makes
business and so he goes through example
after example and it it to me it felt
almost like a John Oliver you know when
John Oliver does those Last Week Tonight
things where he just has a monologue
he's like exposing something that
screwed up or like coffeezilla does this
on YouTube or he'll go in and be like
Logan Paul scam people and let me just
expose the whole the grift
he exposed the grift of Regulation and
he's like
dude look at this like covid happens so
they pass these laws about covid testing
and look at this this same test in the
UK or Germany cost like you know seven
times less as it did in the U.S why
because in the U.S it was mandated that
only these two companies tests were
going to be allowed and in Germany it
was a free market so the test the cost
went way down or he would give an
example of um he's like you know here's
the guy who passed this law uh and he
says that these are the only three
vendors that the government can use and
so they charge this crazy amount and
then guess what here's this LinkedIn oh
what do you know five years later he's
on the board as the chief whatever at
that same company that he handed this
prize to and it's like the grift is real
and the thing I loved about this because
you're like Dan that was a great talk
he's like I've been working on this for
like 15 years he's like basically for
the last 15 years every time I saw
something that was just a complete grift
I was screw it's just a effed up part of
the system I wrote it down I made a note
and so he's like this talk is basically
15 years in the making of me kind of uh
observing what screwed up about the way
that Washington works at the end his mic
drop is basically like he's like I
called this talk in a 2008 or 51 that's
the number of miles between San
Francisco and DC and when I talked to
people in DC and they ask you know how
does Silicon Valley you know do so much
Innovation it's because we're so [__]
far away from Washington DC like we're
just away from the poison of the way
that that place works and we're the
farthest possible place away on the map
in the United States from from DC so I
love that talk was there any like
promising parts of it or like this is
gonna change or is it like this is well
at the end they're like
what do we do about this can this change
it's like well the first thing is this
we have to like expose this right like
you know you gotta shine light on it you
know the bacteria sort of grows in the
dark and um the second thing was he was
like you know
uh it's hard because the incentive is
the people who could change the laws
that would say Hey you know maybe if you
write the laws about these companies you
can't trade their stocks for example
right like we said this on the Pod yeah
but the people who need to pass that law
they're the ones who are profiting from
this so he's like it's almost impossible
to change that incentive like it's like
they would have to do that they need so
much pressure in order to make those
changes because uh they're not
incentivized to do it in fact the
opposite their entire incentive is to
keep the system the way it is there's
this interesting thing that's going on
where I don't know anything about the
government I don't remember if it's the
Senate Congress whatever it is but uh it
was like one of the few things that both
a handful of like hard right Republicans
and hard left uh Democrats were agreeing
on where they're like all right we're
going to create like a political Index
Fund where you could only have if you're
a politician you have to you can you can
have money but it must be in this
particular index fund and so like you
can't own individual stocks you know how
Nancy Pelosi is accused of like doing
whatever and then how I think the head
of was it the New York Stock Exchange
there's uh what are the companies uh
like like two weeks before the
government shut down with kovid they
sold a bunch of stocks and like this all
looks suspicious and so they're they're
trying to like argue that there needs to
be a political Index Fund it seems like
a pretty cool idea actually by the way
there's a startup called autopilot I
don't know if you've ever heard of them
they do like uh
like it's like a automated money
management or like you know basically
it's a way to what you can do is you put
your money in the app and then you could
be like oh I want to copy the Michael
burry portfolio and you can just copy
their public portfolio yeah it's cool
what they did that was really so the
business is doing okay and then it's
like growth took off and I was like dude
what happened like incredible chart he's
like we made this Twitter handle called
the Pelosi tracker and they have the
burger the policy tracker and whatever
and the Pelosi dragger has 339 000
followers and it basically every time
she makes a trade they
um
they post about it and so they just dig
through the filings and they it's
hilarious things and and her gains that
she has and like of course somehow Nancy
Pelosi's like happens to be you know she
you know she's uh you know happens to be
up 30 year to date like she's
outperforming Warren Buffett she's
outperforming your favorite hedge fund
guy like it's insane how does this
government I think you know official do
this it's like well maybe they know some
things before some things happen it's
insane
um um it's corrupt that was a genius
growth hack that they did um all right
I'll give you one so this has been going
around Twitter but I went and watched
the whole thing uh it's pretty amazing
so Dion Sanders I'm not I'm not a
football guy you're gonna know I'm not a
sports guy you're gonna know a lot more
about this than I am Deion Sanders he's
now the coach of what is it Colorado
yeah the Buffaloes the Buffaloes and he
um he was on 60 Minutes I think like two
weeks ago and it was pretty amazing they
did like a 12 minute segment on him and
it was really fascinating because I
remember Deion Sanders as being like
this like cocky like Showboat guy and he
is still a little bit of that but he's
incredibly insightful and so basically
uh what's any what university was that
it was a historical black college it was
it Jackson State where he was yeah I
forgot the name of it yeah some not very
popular school he gets into coaching he
he does a decent job there then he gets
recruited to go to Colorado which is a
big deal but what he does is he um
he's doing two interesting things the
first interesting thing that he's doing
is one of his sons is filming the whole
thing it's like his garyvee thing and so
his son is like filming behind the
scenes and posting it on YouTube and
driving uh interests it's really
fascinating what he's doing have you
seen that it's amazing so one of his
sons is the quarterback the starting
quarterback I think another son is on
the team too the other side is like you
know what the cornerback or the yeah I
think he's a cornerback which is what
Dion used to play and then uh the other
stuff the the son that's not playing
football is basically the garyvee Vlog
guy and he's just in the locker room
he's documenting the whole thing and
sharing it on social as they go and
they're just doing a better job of it
than like
you know anybody's doing following that
stuff yeah it's awesome and the second
things that he did was his leadership
skills are really good and they're kind
of shocking because I just thought that
he was just like a meathead and he was
just this really cocky guy nah man the
guy's really insightful and so basically
they show uh like a clip from one of his
first meetings with the team and he
basically he goes I'm here to encourage
most of you to quit the reason being is
you guys are the team's lost so much I
think last year you were like one in 11
so you lost most every game you barely
won a game and the coaching staff
they're all out we got rid of them I'm
here I brought a bunch of my guys here
who I know are good and look here's the
deal uh the coaching staff is to blame
but you know who else is to blame the
kids because the coaching staff probably
recruited a bunch of losers and I'm here
to get you losers to quit and he and and
the the guy on CNN was like hey man
that's a little harsh like these are
kids he goes well look if you are
willing to quit the team because I said
that you're probably weak and you're not
an asset to this company and if you're
gonna let words scare you I need you out
of here and I need the tough guys to
stay and I need you to be an asset and
not a liability and he re-ramped the
roster he brought like 40 play 40 new
players in which is half of a ball team
roster and and 50 left and 50 left they
went into the transfer porter portal and
he goes uh he he's like look
truth is good for the kids this is what
I'm here to teach you football I'm going
to teach you how to how to live life and
be a good man and what you guys need is
truth I need to tell you the truth and I
need to prepare you for the real world
and we're gonna I want a winning team
and he does this other thing where he
goes uh the the interviewer goes so who
do you think is the best football uh
football coach right now in the NCAA he
goes well do you have a mirror that I
could hold up so I can see him he's like
it's me he goes I'm gonna be the best
coach but then he does a good job of
being like humble he's like well I
learned a lot from Nick Saban he's
forgot more about football than I'll
ever know and so I'm looking for a
little Crumbs from him but it was really
inspirational because I think that uh
this type of like uh pound your chest
leadership the way that he delivered it
was really good it was very inspiring on
how to lead a business yeah you know I'm
usually not uh believe it or not that
big of a believer in uh like the effect
of the pregame or halftime speech like
that seems to be like probably overrated
uh in terms of what a coach can do and
vastly underrated is the systems and uh
like habits and standards that you like
enforce and instill
um and so what people are seeing a lot
because it's super viral you share the
halftime speech you share the
the the pre-game speech or the post game
speech and they're and Dion I don't know
if you know between football and uh this
uh between playing football and this he
like became like a pastor like part-time
and so he was like very religious and he
was like given sermons I remember
watching him on TV giving him sermons in
a big white suit
um but if you but if you watch one of
the other things he does he set a bunch
of Standards so he's like
you know day one and almost in the uh
like that book The Score takes care of
itself by uh Bill Walsh where it's like
okay yeah we want to win but the score
will take care of itself if we do these
inputs he said like the famous stories
like he makes the people answer the
phone in the front desk appropriately
yeah and John Wooden did the same thing
he's like we're gonna learn how to lace
up your shoes if you can't if you don't
take the time intention to figure out
how to lace up your shoes just to make a
point of like what we do out there is a
result of how of what we put in let's
let's understand that it is a direct
result of what we put in and so we're
gonna we're gonna monitor that and so uh
one of the things that that they show in
Dion stuff and I saw this when I was at
Duke with Coach K it's like it's the
little things that they said as the
standard so for example he's like you
know
if you are on the field he said put up
he put up footage from the previous
practice he's like look at what's
Happening Here can anyone tell me what's
wrong and it's like I don't know it's
not even a play what are you talking
about like it's nothing this is just us
walking in between the drills like he's
like exactly you're walking if we were
on this field we run we do not walk and
he's like basically created a new set of
standards and so he's like if you're in
a team meeting where do you sit how do
you show up do you use your phone do you
do and he's just like kind of like
instilling these standards so while the
speeches are getting a lot of the the
the the the shine I think the more
interesting thing is basically in the
how we show up uh the daily standards of
the inputs uh that go into it and now of
course you know they're undefeated right
now and they're doing really well and I
think it's more because of that
yeah it's awesome and he the he did a
good job where he was like when the guy
was like when he did the whole thing
like let me hold up the mirror and he
was like well look here's the deal I
tell my kids I go I expect you to be the
best so I'm gonna be the best too and
he's like you're I think you can win the
Heisman Trophy and I think I'm gonna be
the best coach and so he does a really
good job of balancing this like cocky
we're gonna take over the world and also
uh high expectations so I thought that
was really inspiring what do you got all
right I'll do another one um this is in
the nerdy realm so there's a guy who is
a Twitter account I really like called
CFO Secrets I love this guy he has a
newsletter that
um I didn't subscribe to but I just saw
one of his posts that was really great
it was uh it was called uncovering The
Mystery of working capital and M A I was
like okay that sounds like you know
boring has a market size of like three
people right now it's just like dude
when we when I sold the HubSpot it took
me a week to under for them to explain
what working capital was and I still
don't understand it read this post it's
really good so one of the things that I
look for is like you know you can tell
when somebody actually knows their [__]
and off honestly like sometimes when I
go on Twitter or I go on YouTube I just
want to delete my account because I'm
like
it's so annoying that the most vocal
people just don't know what the hell
they're talking about
um and there and what happens is some
people know what they're talking about
they produce content everybody loves it
but then some people instead of taking
that content and going and executing on
it they're like I too will create
content about how to be successful
although I am not successful yet and
then they do it and then there's like a
ladder below that and they're like I
will tell people how to do sales even
though I've never done sales even though
I don't know anything about sales even
though I've only sold ten thousand
dollars in my life right like and it
just ladders down in that way and then
and those people have the most time on
their hands so they're the most like
active uh publishing stuff it's crazy
so seeing this guy's newsletter I was
like oh finally somebody who knows what
they're talking about so he has this
thing about M A and if you ever sold a
company so much of what he says Rings
true he's like so he he's like the post
starts like this I'm just going to read
you some of the best parts of it goes it
always starts the same we're tired
they're tired
um everyone's been sprinting get this
over the line and we're sprinting
because time kills deals and he's like
if you've done deals you know this
momentum is what oils the deal wheels
and he's like there's always a point
where the deal is mostly agreed we've
agreed on the headline valuation number
and that took a lot of negotiating it's
tired us out and now there's only two or
three points left to agree in the deal
he's like most of these are boring stuff
like reps and warranties and the legal
documents and we want to leave that to
learn there's maybe one Commercial Point
left
and so the other side picks up the phone
and they say hey we just uh we just need
to iron out this one detail about
working capital Peg
and he goes I'll say something like oh
thanks for the ride I've been so busy on
the on the documents I haven't had much
time to give that thought I'll get back
to you tonight but I've thought about it
I've been thinking about it I've been
thinking about the working capital this
whole time I'm just setting up my
position that way that oh I haven't
really brought it you know I haven't
even put much thought into it and then
I'm going to bring them a very well
thought through thing that I think is uh
gonna make sense and he goes there's one
last trade left in the negotiation
in my experience this is one to three
percent of your total Enterprise Value
is just this last thing and it's a pure
win lose negotiation between both sides
you're tired they're tired who's gonna
feel like ah screw it let's just get the
deal done and I'm like and you know we
just went through a negotiation so you
know this and then by the way that's
what I learned from you about
negotiating you're you had a line that
actually changed me which was the the
person who can be comfortable with the
most amount of uncomfortableness will
will win exactly yeah the short version
of that I say in every negotiation is
the more stubborn party wins always
uh people think that the person who wins
a negotiation is the one who has the
stronger logical case hell no it's the
person who's more stubborn who wins
always and
um how do you be stubborn you need to be
comfortable in the UN in the discomfort
and I would say honestly when we did
this negotiation which maybe we should
do by saying by the way a breakdown on
the whole thing one of the one of the
things I think we did not do a good job
of was this last bit the last point
which is that last you know one to five
percent of value and we were just so
tight we just wanted to get the deal
done I don't think we did a good job
like four months yeah and I think that
the real way to do that is that's when
you need to like dig in the most because
it's that last deal point that like you
can get and you'll thank yourself later
for it even though in the moment you're
feeling tired it's like any workouts
like do I push here or do I just say I'm
tired and I stop and like anybody who
knows about workouts is like no push
through yes you're tired but you'll feel
So Satisfied and all the gains will come
on that those last two reps of pushing
it
um so anyways he talks about this and
then he gets into the nerdy part where
he's like all right here's a spreadsheet
like you know you have your Enterprise
Value
and then you have your Equity your value
your actual valuation what's the
difference between the two it's like
well your Enterprise Value includes the
debt and the capital that's in the
business and then your valuation you
know your the actual Equity value is
what's left after that so I think just a
very useful doc a very useful newsletter
for people who are going to go through
that or going through that probably
Overkill to read this early but if
you're going to do uh m a
it really really pays to have somebody
who's good at M A on your side
um when we were doing our negotiation I
was basically trying to convince you hey
let's have our buddy who's done more M A
than both of us like help us think this
through at the beginning you you did
good you led that one and you did really
good and I would say I'm still like
intermediate maybe I'm at the early
stage of intermediate there's people who
are way more advanced and so uh anyways
this is a newsletter it's a very nerdy
find for m a I'm gonna read this I I
went through this I went through a deal
that involved networking capital I still
don't entirely know what it means um it
was this was very challenging and the
guys this guy's writing is really good
and he actually sets it up perfectly
where like networking Capital was thrown
in at the last minute and I'm like oh I
don't I don't even know what that is I'm
dead I I want to get this done it's
supposed to close in eight days I just
want to get this done yeah
worst have you heard of HubSpot see most
trms are a cobble together mess but
HubSpot is easy to adopt and actually
looks gorgeous I think I love our new
CRM operator is the best
the best HubSpot grow better
[Music]
hey guys really quick so you may know
this but my beginning in business was
being a copywriter I'm a self-talk
copywriter and what that means is I
figured out what motivated people and
then I figured out how to use the
written word to get them to do what I
want them to do so that could mean
selling them a product that could mean
writing a speech or even giving a speech
and giving someone to buy into a
particular movement it could be
recruiting hell you could do it for
dating it just basically means figuring
out what motivates someone and how to
use the written word to take an action
get them to take an action or to think a
certain way and the way that I learned
how to copyright was I did this thing
called copywork and copywork is this
famous technique that's not really
popular anymore but it used to be really
really popular and you basically take
writing that is great writing that you
love and you write it out by hand and
you copy it and you make notes of what
particular thing that that writer is
doing that makes it special this is the
exact same way that you learn how to
play the piano when you want to learn
how to play the piano you learn how to
play Happy Birthday and then you learn
how to play like Jingle Bells and then
maybe like a rock and roll song and then
maybe like a hip-hop song and eventually
you can combine that all together after
a few years and you learn how to make
music that you're your own same thing
with writing that's how I learned how to
write I locked myself in a room for six
months and I just did this for many
hours a day
I created a program to make it easy so
you could do that it's called copy that
copy that.com you can go there and you
can check it out to 10 day exercise to
make it really easy to learn how to
write if you want you can just go do
this on your own you can find great
writing and just literally copy it by
hand I know it sounds crazy but it works
really effectively but I made something
that makes it a little bit easier so
check it out copythat.com and we will
talk soon and back to the Pod you want
to go to to the last one oh yeah okay so
do you know this account cultural tutor
on Twitter awesome follow awesome
follow-ups so the story is kind of crazy
I didn't really know about it but he he
went on David perrell's podcast which I
think you you were going on too or
something I just uh I just recorded an
episode with them last week so David Pro
cool guy lives in I think Austin and
he's uh teaches people like about
writing online
he's got a new podcast so he did an
episode
and the set itself is beautiful it looks
like they're in like you know the Royal
Library in the UK or something beautiful
set so he has this guy on I've never
heard of this guy
and then I was like oh I did see one of
his threads go super viral he did a
thread about like why all architecture
designs all look the same now they're
all minimalist and that thing got like
100 million likes or some [__] like that
it was really good it was really weird
and it's not even about like a thing you
would think goes viral but it hit a
nerve and so this guy he does his
interview and I've only honestly I've
only listened to the first 10 minutes of
this so like many books I recommend I
got a lot of value out of the first 10
minutes and I was sort of satisfied
but he said something at the beginning
so he's like this guy was basically
working at McDonald's literally he was
like flipping burgers and doing french
fries and he's like
um they had like a mutual friend this
guy Harry dry who's cool and uh then
David I think David like basically
sponsored him he became like his Patron
he's like you want to write what if I
just paid you to write
so he quits his job at McDonald's he
just decides okay I'm gonna write every
day and David like funds him for
whatever reason I don't know exactly how
this [__] worked but like I'm sure they
explained it in the other 50 minutes of
the podcast
but the important part is not that the
important part is this guy then decides
okay I'm gonna write one amazing Twitter
thread a day
and he says this line that's great he's
like um
he's like and then David's like what's
your schedule he's like he's like yeah I
wake up at like 4 P.M
and then I just start thinking about my
thread and I smoke cigarettes I go for
walks I write I go for another walk
smoke some more cigarettes and then I
you know I'll eat some food if somewhere
in the middle there and then I'll just
write and then I publish and then I pass
out and I do it again the next day
he's like that's crazy he's like yeah
um I don't he's like you know I'm not
the guy who's gonna tell you my morning
routine don't follow me but like this is
what I do and he's like I just my whole
day is about publishing one amazing
Twitter then he said this line that I
love he goes that sounds silly I
understand that that my whole day is
just about posting on Twitter
but everybody's just got a thing that's
my thing okay and he's like we've all
got one thing that's my thing
I was like I love it and he's like what
are the results have been so far he's
got 1.3 million Twitter followers he's
got an insane Twitter following like
he's built a ma in like a year is it
making money I don't know I don't think
he makes any money off it yet but you
can right like you know it's not that
hard to turn attention into money once
you have attention
um you know it's harder to turn money
into attention than it is attention into
money to be honest he has 1.5 and he has
a hundred thousand person email list
yeah he's doing fantastic that's that's
incredible right so he's doing doing
very very well for himself uh you know
but I just love the intensity this guy
was gonna bring to something and I've
actually noticed this as a common trait
which is if you bring a level of
seriousness to something that everybody
else considers not serious
you can actually win much bigger than
most people realize that's how we felt
about newsletters I was like well I'm
doing the math I think this could be a
legit thing and we sold early but we
definitely the business could make 100
million dollars a year you know morning
Brew is close to that and I always say
one of the reasons why is people thought
this was silly but if you did the math
I'm like I don't know I think the math
is out there I think this is going to be
a real thing
um and I think that's the same thing
with my latest business as well which is
we're just taking something seriously
that most used as a hobby yeah I don't
know if that's true is that true aren't
there like you know does YPO not take
this seriously do those guys not take it
seriously they do but most uh there's a
there's a few that do but many many
others in the space they think that it's
just like uh it's like a small thing
that you charge 100 a year for or
something like that
um there's a lot of there's a lot of
hobbyists the better frame I think for
what you're doing to be honest is just
the is that we joke about it but it is
the
beautifully done like I am trying to do
that your [__] is just more stylish and
more cool and more desirable
for a variety of intangible factors
ranging from design to people feeling
fomo to content to
um you know the the the the first
hundred members that you added to your
thing
um
like I remember getting sales calls to
join whatever what a vistage or whatever
the hell they missed the mark they
missed the mark well what I I love guys
like cultural tutor because what I do
for a lot of my Brands is I follow
people like him and I look at like what
was cool in the 60s and 70s that I can
just reuse today so for example our
color for Hampton it's uh the color of
this really cool Jaguar car that was
popular in the 70s right and then when I
made The Branding I found old Rolex ads
because I'm like what was cool then that
could still be cool now there's another
example have you seen the sunscreen
company that's doing that uh vacation
where it like it looks like an 80s or
early 90s like a guy who did vacation
this guy Jeremy Summers he he's amazing
The Branding for us for milk Road oh he
didn't really character but he helped us
develop the whole brand and then the
last bit was he we didn't love the
character and then we had a different
guy do the drawing the illustration for
it but he did our branding yeah that for
milk grow Jeremy did an amazing job and
he's that's specifically his aesthetic
um is that kind of like
I don't know if I I shouldn't say that
he's really good at that aesthetic which
is the like kind of vintage classy like
you know nostalgic
um beautifully done uh sort of aesthetic
by the way I'll we'll wrap up with a
quick story about David Pro I went to
his apartment so basically he lives in
uh Austin he has an apartment in the
building but then he also rented this
other apartment and when you walk in it
feels almost like an Airbnb or maybe
like you're walking into like a
Restoration Hardware Store everything is
perfectly set up and David is really OCD
and so like he's got this two bedroom or
it was a three-bedroom apartment they
knocked down one wall so they went all
in on this thing and then one room is
like the studio where we sit and then
another room is like the guest room
where if you're a guest and you want to
fly in you could stay there but like
there's like a record on the wall or
there's books on the shelf and I'm like
David all these have a meeting he goes
he's of course you know me you know
every single here every single thing
here has a purpose and has a story and
so he like perfectly like picked
everything in this studio and what is
that
oh would you like to see this
cream-colored book that's on my
bookshelf does it even have pages in it
maybe this one says
what does it say Tango lessons
um Tango lessons did I read this book no
did I go on Etsy because somebody said
go buy cream colored books to put in
your background makes you look classy
dude everything at David's place is on
purpose and it all has a story and I
sent you a video and I'm like we have to
step it up this guy is so particular
it's it's he's the Deion Sanders uh in
my world of podcasting right now he did
an outrageous comp all of his standards
were perfect and like I saw his trailer
oh my God the guy's sweating the details
David's awesome he does a great job he's
gotten way further with a topic that I
think is incredibly boring like he makes
millions of dollars a year doing right
of passage like getting people to become
like [__] novelists or something
I don't know how he does that that's not
even a thing I think people want to do
uh like you know write long essays like
um I'm a like to me that is these are 10
out of 10 execution on a 4 out of 10
opportunity
um you know like if he was doing like
whatever used card sales he'd be the
he'd be like a trillionaire right
because it's like dude he's obsessed
with it though he loves it of course of
course he's doing it for the right
reasons he's so obsessed for it I think
he said this publicly I met him two
years ago and he's he's a he's Jewish he
uh ethnically I I I don't know
religiously I don't know if he was as
well but he went to a Bible study class
every day or once a week and I was like
why are you doing this Bible study class
he's like well the Bible's really
important because it's just like part of
culture yeah he's like I'm just so
fascinated with like writing and like
I've noticed there's a lot of Bible
references so he started going those
Bible class well I see him again after
about a year and he's like I've
converted to Christianity they got me
like like I just read it so much and I
thought you know I really want to go one
step further and I want to become a
Christian and say what the Stig is all
about like he is an academic in like a
very at like in the coolest way possible
but he's like I wanted bought into this
whole thing hardcore I was trying to
flirt with him instead of sending nudes
I just sent him a font and uh he was
over the moon about it loved it it's
like oh that is that jaran that made me
weak at the knees
let's recap him real quick so we got the
bill Gurley talk that's a Youtube video
um the David Pearl interview with
cultural tutor watched the first 10
minutes it's great and uh what was yours
yours was the Deion Sanders on 16
minutes Deion Sanders 60 minutes and
then the secret CFO newsletter about
nerdy M A stuff there's like a series
it's like a 19 part series and I read
two of them and they're very good all
right that's the pod
[Music]